so thanks for attending um
we're going to have a little bit of a
different presentation than i think most
of you seeing in the other ones
you won't see any code in this one
it's really about our experience the
three of us
as a team and building out an internal
ecosystem of python tools and packages
that
serve to scale
and make our data scientists more
efficient in their work
so in doing so i'm going to kind of kick
this off give you a little bit of
introduction of who we are um who the
who the company that we work for is and
kind of uh introduce the ecosystem we've
developed over the last um
let's see
sorry i was just trying to see if the
video thing worked over the last two
years
and then i'm gonna hand it off to ethan
and gus and they're really gonna talk
about probably the more important things
in this presentation and that's like the
key themes that we have found that have
made this ecosystem successful
all right so who are we um so we got
some short introductions earlier on by
marcelo thank you again so my name is
brad we got ethan and gus here and we
all work for the same company 8451 um
and and actually we all work for the
same team
within the company and we sit on a
specialized team within the company that
basically serves to build internal tools
for a data scientist and when i say
internal tools i would say 95 of that
are python packages
so we are we are all data scientists but
we are really wearing software
engineering hats and building tools for
other data scientists
so who's this company we work for
you likely have not heard of 8451 even
if you do live in the states but you may
have heard of kroger kroger is the
largest supermarket
retailer would i say supermarket i think
grocery store chains
within the us
and they are the third largest retailer
in the us behind amazon and walmart
and and they own 8451 and 8451 is a
company that
focuses on doing data science for kroger
and also for all the companies that
supply products to kroger so you think
coca-cola free-to-lay all those products
that get sold in kroger and we do a lot
of the data science for marketing and
product placement within
kroger right so the company has actually
grown quite a bit over the last few
years we have
over 250 data scientists so
likely wherever you work that's probably
a pretty
large amount of data scientists for a
single company
that is rare
and the way that we work is we are
highly matrix which just means we have
data scientists embedded on teams
alongside engineers some r d folks
business consultants project managers
and so on and that's that's worked
fantastic
but with any growing company
we've experienced some some pains
as we've added more data scientists
more data science projects we've added
more compute environments we do operate
in
azure gcp and we also have on-prem
hadoop
and so with that what we have
experienced is a lot of duplication and
code and also code inconsistencies and
just some
some common procedures common code
procedures that we do throughout the
company
and and this is really what kind of
forced our com our our team to kind of
come into existence
and we spent the last three years
building out an ecosystem of internal
packages python packages
that serve to simplify
and make a lot of these code procedures
common across the different teams and
also to scale
the work so you can see we have a lot of
packages that are focused on providing
ease and data access
to be able to do
basic data wrangling aggregation some
modeling tasks
managing our environments and then also
some developer tools
and so
just as a real quick example like how do
these data scientists use these packages
well for a given problem for example if
a data scientist needs to
compute some
key performance metrics for a certain
product sold
in certain kroger stores across the us
they could actually take these different
lego
pieces or different internal python
packages
to do
parts of this task right so it could be
setting up their spark configuration in
a efficient manner
they could be using another package to
work with the different types of kroger
fiscal dates that we have
they may use another package to
be able to
identify wrangle and extract upc
information about a certain product and
so on so the idea is
that we have all these different
packages that serve different parts of
that data science workflow and the data
scientists can just kind of plug and
play with these python packages to
simplify their procedures
all right so
the benefits that we've seen i'm not
going to read all these bullets but
really it comes down to
faster innovation faster data science
development it allows them to scale
their work much quicker and better
governance so we have data scientists
that are performing common procedures
in a similar manner and we we can pretty
much guarantee when they use these
packages that they are doing it in the
way that's become accepted as a best
practice within the company
all right so what do we've seen with
this ecosystem well just to give you an
idea um we are well over 25 000 function
calls per month
and we typically have over a hundred
distinct data scientist users from
within the company using these packages
each month
so that's kind of an idea behind like
the ecosystem we created but really what
we want to talk about for the rest of
this presentation is what are some of
the key themes that we have found as we
develop this ecosystem that have made it
successful and that's kind of where
ethan and gus are gonna jump in so ethan
yeah thanks brad
um so we're gonna move through a lot of
these slides pretty fast there's a fair
amount of content but i actually sent a
link to the presentation to the chat so
if anybody wants to come back and look
at some of these slides more you're more
than welcome to um just a heads up as we
we go fast because we have a lot
um so how how do you begin to identify
what sorts of things you should be
building tooling around because you know
we're we're saying that there's a lot of
cases where you want the standardization
or you want simplicity but how do i you
identify the places where you can
actually um help the company basically
so our recommendation is really to look
for tasks that are specific to your
company or your team or maybe even your
industry um that usually means that
either there's a lot of business logic
involved or there's something about the
systems you use that is complex for some
reason maybe authentication
configuration
but we would warn you not to go for
things that are common problems across
data science
if a problem is common across all of
data science like a modeling pipeline
for example
those things are probably either solved
in common libraries like scikit-learn
and pandas or they're very difficult um
that would be why there isn't some kind
of tool that already exists for them so
be cautious about that
mostly you're looking for things that
are about your company or your industry
um you want to take us to the next one
brad thanks so some examples that we've
seen uh are things like internal sets of
rules that you apply to data sets before
you analyze them
so you can allow users to customize to
some degree if you want toggle things on
or off but basically apply what you
might call like golden rules for best
practice
um industry standard metrics so maybe
like median units sold per household but
excluding returns that's the kind of
thing that a retailer might calculate
things like that that are standard in
your company but
users have to write the code for every
time often
internal systems that require
configuration or authentication i
mentioned that before we use that for
things like spark apache spark and some
of our databases and then also if your
company has a fiscal calendar that they
use often and analyses work over that
fiscal calendar it's good to provide a
translation layer for users to go to and
from that calendar from the traditional
gregorian calendar
okay
next one brad thanks
so if um if you're working on this how
how do you think about the problem of
actually developing a tool and not
exactly from the code perspective but
just generally like what should your
mindset be
um so there's really two
there's scope build release we call it
and prototype and evolve and these are
two very different things you want to
take us to the next one
so in scope build release basically
you're concentrating on getting the
problem right and solving it correctly
the first time and that usually means
gathering a lot of info to begin um and
that means uh basically a lot a lot of
planning and something more like a
product
management mindset where you're going to
gather information figure out the right
thing to build work through it and then
release it to users and that's in
contrast with the other one
prototype and evolve
and in that case actually this is a
little more of like a hacker mindset
where you quickly tackle problems that
you see
you're willing to pivot and maybe not
end up solving the problem you started
on based on what's doable instead of
what is like high value for example
a big focus on the problems you can
solve and regularly redesign what the
product is um and that usually comes
down to something like interface
so we actually like that second one um
so if you take us to the next slide brad
thanks um
you find out whether the thing you're
working on is buildable much earlier
which is really nice because often we
have found that if you get lost in the
sort of product management mindset in
tools like this you don't get things out
to your users fast enough and you're not
able to pivot based on whether something
is doable and whether it's actually
useful
and also you should think about internal
infrastructure as sort of like lottery
tickets where some will only be used by
a few people but some will be used by
very many and by producing more things
you have a much better chance of hitting
on those lottery tickets
next slide please
so some some advice about using this
prototype and evolve mindset um try to
avoid getting lost in value
quantification that can take a long time
it does perhaps make sense with external
clients but when you're building
infrastructure for your own company
often that's very slow and prone to
scope creep getting distracted
um instead follow simpler heuristics
around like what do people find
frustrating at work just to solve the
things people find annoying
um that usually leads you in the right
direction be willing to work fast and
pivot fast throw together prototypes and
throw them away sometimes
and be willing to change what you're
working on if you realize along the way
that you have another problem that might
be easy to solve produce a tool for that
and publish that publish that and feel
free to not go in the original direction
and also don't don't try to integrate a
bunch of different teams needs into a
single tool sometimes that works but
often it's actually more trouble than
it's worth and you don't end up
producing something useful to anyone in
your attempt to make something useful
for everyone
next section please
um so when you actually dig into the
code how should you think about where to
spend your time and what sorts of uh
work should be done there
basically our advice here boils down to
focus more on the interface than the
implementation
this is a hacker mindset like we said
it's about throwing things together um
and it really doesn't matter if they're
fast if they're performant uh if they're
built in the optimal way under the hood
what matters is if they're usable um
they need to solve the problem and be
usable and that's really all you need at
the beginning you can come back and work
on the underlying implementation later
but you often don't get a chance to
redesign your interface because users
become attached to it even if it's not
officially anything passed to beta users
just get attached to things and they're
hard to change
so if you take us to the next slide what
we recommend is
working on the initial implementation
and interface together and then do some
iterating on the interface alone toy
around with it maybe in a jupyter
notebook play around with the api you've
designed decide if it's useful maybe
redesign it do that a few times before
you make your first release but there's
no need to do that on your
implementation is the point we're making
here it's about the interface that you
need to get
right okay next slide please
um so some other advice about interface
design
interfaces matter a lot so a coherent uh
lead is really useful having one person
who really sets the tone for what the
interface is like makes it feel more
cohesive and makes people catch on to it
faster
be careful about naming it's very easy
just to be sloppy about names and not
pay attention to things that like
functions that aren't present tense
verbs and things like that but that'll
come back to bite you later when you
can't break backwards compatibility keep
the public api limited at the beginning
you can always come back to that and
change it later but at the beginning
keep it simple
the helper functions are probably going
to change because you are
making the implementation a bit of a
hack at the beginning right
um and always remember that this is a
contract so beta interfa beta interfaces
might last forever even though you don't
want them to so just just be cautious
and always keep that in mind
and then the next slide please
after you have something working how do
you build and keep iterating um we'll
release often uh that's very important
because you get more feedback from users
more often use versioning uh
specifically we recommend semantic
versioning because you can signal when
you have breaking changes with major
version bumps
uh have a deprecation policy it's hard
to have one uh before your 1.0 version
but having something in place is useful
and be responsive to your users but
remember that you control vision not the
users and if you think something is
worth building and is doable you are the
only one who can make that call
if that rankles people who have some
sway
it is not the worst thing sometimes to
let something sit on the backlog for a
while um that's okay if if that means
that you can actually work on more
important stuff in other places
okay and then i think i'll pass it off
to gus for the next couple seconds
thanks ethan all right so we talked
about um
how we kind of look at building tools
and getting them up and running but
obviously there's more to
uh good tools than just that right let
me go next slide
all right so good tools are more than
just their code your ultimate goal both
in building tools and maintaining tools
is reducing friction and that goes
just as much for how you enhance your
code
if you reduce friction your developers
can more easily contribute and maintain
your package you get happier happier
coders and it makes your users more
independent and how they learn how and
how they learn about your package or
your tool and how they use it and it
keeps them off your back right if they
know how to use it they don't need to
bug you about every little detail
we go next slide
right so one of the big things that we
always recommend is testing suite
unit testing all that kind of thing
automation through ci cd
uh
contribution guide with instructions how
to use suite so that your developers
aren't just sitting there knowing that
there's a testing suite but they should
know how to use it to check their code
uh coming to the next slide
yeah right what does this get you
developers can easily check their work
if they have a testing suite
it makes it easier for them to check
what's working still and what they might
have broken while they're trying to make
updates
in general it helps you identify bugs
earlier
obviously testing is heavily going to
help your developers but it helps your
users in that
if you're identifying bugs earlier and
your developers have a way to check that
they're integrating your code properly
they get more stable releases and then
your users are happier they don't worry
about
bugs creeping in as often it can work
you know your api is generally stable
it just helps a lot
uh next slide
another big pillar that you'll see that
we like to recommend a lot is
documentation right for having a good
readme to having a change log to having
a contributing guide which you mentioned
before testing but
obviously that goes beyond just testing
and then having a website
with guides on how to install how to use
uh both at a high level and then a more
detailed level an api guide and then
especially for
when we're talking about creating tools
within businesses any business logic
that's not
necessarily obvious from your code or
gives more context to how why your code
works the way it does all that should be
documented
in the next slide
right
documentation as opposed to testing is
going to be very
helpful to your users because they can
get started quickly independently and it
gives them a good place to go first with
the question if they can go to your
documentation answer the majority of
their questions
they don't bug you with it they can and
you can get all their common questions
answered and then they can come to you
when they have something deeper
to ask about or something that isn't
quite clear in documentation or a bug
report
and on the development side
if there's a contribution guide and an
api guide
new developers can learn how to get
started with contributing and also they
can learn about your existing
functionality so not only do they see
the source code but they can understand
what kind of mindset what kind of
decisions have already been made in your
code and then they can know better how
their contributions should fit into your
code
next slide
and then finally issue tracking just
basic things of having issues to submit
bugs and enhancements and some kind of
progress tracker we used to use some
kind of kanban board
next slide
big thing users have a direct line to
your workflow
um similar to what ethan said before
you're not beholden to your users when
they request things or they submit
anything but it gives you a transparent
line of communication about
what they want what you're doing and how
what's being released and also if you're
using something like github you get
documentation of all those issues and
their solutions for future reference so
that way people keep getting bugs or
something else keeps coming up you have
that built in
uh next slide
all right so
um
so we have we've talked about tools how
to build how to document all that kind
of things but you need to maintain that
quality right if you just build
something and leave it it's not going to
mean anything um people are gonna stop
using in there and find something else
we're gonna build something themselves
uh so our two pillars of long-term
quality are responses and refactoring
you know you've got a user side and
development side
uh next slide
so when you're working with users you
got to remember that they are part of
your maintenance process it's not just
you and your developers it's the user so
you need to be responsive
literally respond to issues as they log
them just acknowledge they've been
received ask for clarifying details so
that way you can
um understand what's going on and
explain as you're implementing solutions
and have discussions about it and then
share progress with this as you're
releasing things so that way everyone
understands what's happening and they
can get their new code faster
next slide
uh we also mentioned refactoring right
so we have the developer side of this
next one
obviously clearcode helps everyone
across every facet of development um you
can see maintaining implementing
onboarding encouraging outside
contributions having clearer code helps
across the board
next slide
please
uh so the big thing is to be strategic
you don't want to be planning
refactoring for every single cycle or
whatever work session you're using but
you don't want to be just sporadically
tacky on refactoring into pr's that have
nothing to do with it you want to strike
a balance on trying to get that work
done without taking up too much of your
time because you have other stuff to do
something that helps with that is if you
put
potential refactoring ideas on your
backlog then you have a quantifiable
work work item to come back to you later
um but however you want to do it the big
thing is do it in smaller units even if
you're planning to refactor a big
section of your package
do it in as small as you can do it in
phases all that kind of stuff
uh next slide
all right so kind of high level
takeaways um so
really the the purpose of our ecosystem
has been around
um addressing issues when we've seen
enterprise growth and really growth
amongst a data science team
so
as data science teams kind of grow
significantly large you tend to see
stove pipe processes code duplication
and code inconsistencies that happen
across the company
and trying to
resolve those we have found to be
extremely
easier by doing it through foundational
inner source packages um the inner
source tools inner source python
packages have really helped to kind of
simplify and scale common data science
tasks
and so what are some of the things that
we have found
um as we've done this uh ethan and gus
kind of hit on them
many different lessons learned um around
like how do we identify the problems
that we want to work on
how do we do early development which we
really focus on kind of quick prototype
releasing very early versus very large
monolithic projects
with a long-term release date
and we really focus on the interface
that's something that we have found to
be extremely important where
as we put out more of these inner source
tools
the more common that we have the
interface look across them um the easier
it is for our data scientists to really
kind of get up to speed and start
working with them
and then some of the stuff that gus
talked about
maintenance long-term support of our
packages
is extremely important putting the time
and effort into refactoring and also
having that relationship with the end
users we have found to be extremely uh
important and beneficial in the success
of these packages being adopted
so with that marcelo we will
just hand it over for any
questions sure thank you very much
that's going to be fine there are some
questions by the participants
and
ethan was providing some support
with them
dilip was asking about
what tools have you used to keep track
of usage and metrics on your created
packages
yeah so let ethan talk to that one
because he actually developed a
fantastic logging tool that we use
internally
thanks brad do you want to show the
final slide we have an appendix slide
that mentions some of the internal
packages we use and that's actually
mentioned so i i did respond in the chat
but just to mention that um
basically what we found is yeah internal
packages and tools uh often
are of interest like their usage amount
is of interest to leadership and to the
people developing them and we
basically went in with a goal of how
simple can we make it to add usage
metric collection um so we have a
package which we call component logger
but all it does is expose a python
decorator there's really almost nothing
else users will ever see of the package
but adding the decorator to functions
and classes in another internal tool
will
automatically do logging for them and it
handles complications like in what
platform are you running what database
do you have access to write the logs to
so it writes to different databases in
different spots
and then we have other tools to go back
and read those logs but it really is
mainly for
what you might call uh like telemetry
like it's just sort of basic information
about usage and when and who
and then i i think there's another
question oh sorry brad
no i was just going to say i i think one
of the important things to kind of call
out about that is that was some initial
logging that we did and i think what has
helped a lot is ethan turn that process
into a package
and so what that does is it makes it
easy for other teams across the the
company that are building internal
packages just to go ahead and throw that
in as a dependency and they pretty much
automatically start logging themselves
so we made it very easy to do logging by
turning that procedure into an internal
package
yeah and that that's actually a bit of a
callback to some of the other stuff we
talked about during the session where
interface is so important compared to
the implementation like originally that
was a total hack but we did give people
a really easy simple interface to use
and by providing something like that we
got initial users and then we were able
to improve the underlying functionality
over time we didn't have to do it all
from the very beginning
the other question uh gus did you see
that one i think that would be a good
one for you about
philosophies or rules of thumb around
deprecating libraries and functions
yeah um
so obviously um we talked about throwing
away tools we don't want to deprecate
libraries that often but it comes up and
we deprecate functions a lot more often
the the big thing like we talked about
is communication
um so we do use our our component logger
to try to figure out how much people are
using
different aspects of our library so that
way we can kind of tell
without even gathering without even
having to talk to users and trying to
get their input we can kind of see
who's using what is something falling by
the wayside and kind of deprecate it or
if we're looking at making breaking
changes who's using it and
can we talk to them about new interfaces
or just make sure that they're aware
but the key to doing all that is
it's just communication um
we we try to
which even outside the application when
we're just doing releases if we're doing
a major release with breaking changes we
send out a lot of advanced notice of hey
this is how the api is going to change
take a look start pinning your packages
that way you can have a chance to test
it before everything goes into
production
um
we're going to minor releases where we
just start adding new features but we
want people to know about it so that
they're
not caught off guard by having this new
thing that could help them a lot um
we'll send out emails um
ahead of time and as it's released
um when you look at deprecating it's the
same kind of philosophy just
as much advanced notes as you can so
that people can adjust their situation
and when we have time we'll also
if we're deprecating for a specific
reason like to give it to give a new
package for that purpose we'll
start providing guides to
show how to convert your code from the
deprecated library to the new library or
if another team's developed a solution
that's a better use case
how to get to their library
um
it's really just being transparent about
it
all right so there are some other
questions from the participants
tim smith is asking how do you support
discovery of your tools among your
clients your client teams
yeah i think um
we are in a good position there where
we're kind of a team within the company
known specifically for creating internal
tools um so that's nice because we tend
to have a lot of touch points with other
teams and they do look at some of the
documentation we produce so they run
into these but also you can't
underestimate how many people are going
to just kind of tune out in a company
and not pay attention to that kind of
stuff
so really what you have to rely on is
that a few users who really like the
tool will tell their friends about it
basically is what it comes down to you
have to find like an evangelist user
base basically
thanks a lot
another question by one participant is
this
i'm developing an internal back cache
but i need to support python 3.6 to 3.9
so i was trying portrait to manage
dependencies
with back ported stuff like data
database classes
and a recommendation on supporting a
wide range of environments
did somebody else want to take that one
yeah i mean i think uh
i don't think we have a a great response
to that we do have a few different
environments uh like internally on our
on-prem system i think we're in like a
three-six
maybe a three-seven um and then
we've got what three-eighths in a cloud
environment
the main thing i think that we do
to
get around that is we
we don't look to
put in like the latest and greatest
syntax adoptions within a release
we try to keep it simple something that
is across the different environments
we are starting now to get into the
process of trying to do testing like
when we do our unit tests we will
actually try to run them across
different python versions that's
something that we we've actually just
recently started
talking about more and started doing so
it's something that that is something we
are working through
and i think that the main thing to think
about is one how can you do testing to
test across the different environments
that you have and then two
don't necessarily get to get wild and
crazy on adopting like the latest and
greatest syntax changes within a single
uh
environment
or version change
yeah and one very small thing i would
add to that um
some good guidance is test on the lowest
version of python anyone's going to use
run your tests on that and
run your type checking on a newer
version if you're going to use type
checking because you've got a lot of
conveniences and type checking in the
newer versions of python and you could
be more expressive and get better checks
out of my pie
but what matters is that the code
imports and runs not necessarily that
the type checking works but that the
code imports and runs in the oldest
version of python and that usually means
you'll be fine all the way up to the
newest as long as that's like after
python 3 basically so if you follow that
advice you're probably going to be fine
and those things pass you're probably
going to be fine 95 of the time
all right thank you very much that's
another question from raju
he's asking
well actually uh it's a set of questions
but i will mention them in ones the
first one is did you face any roadblocks
or communicate incoming or communicating
to management right
management regarding setting this up
since setting this up is kind of non
billable work
management or
executive team might not see the value
in it
that's the question from radio
yeah i know this is a good question um
so i would say
we did not necessarily get a lot of
roadblocks um initially from management
they realized that we had
inconsistencies across many teams
and they they really gave us some
freedom in trying to address that
but i think what was important early on
was we showed some quick wins
and we had a few different tools and
packages that got adopted
um significantly and quickly across a
lot of teams
and i think that made management
understand just like the scale at which
we can improve performance and uh and
code consistency across the company and
i think once we got those early quick
wins um it was
it was pretty simple to sell the need of
new tools when they came up
all right
thank you very much
well
i think
there are no more questions by the
participants
many of them are thanking you all of
three very much dilip i want to uh thank
you for your time and your amazing
presentation i actually enjoy
having a session of a full team a full
data science scientist team right like
working together in order to follow
their job experiences as companies are
following today right
so
i want to also thank all attendants who
participated with their questions it was
such a wonderful experience